[Music]
hey what is up guys
Mk PhD here and this is it this is the
Google pixel excel in the flesh we
finally have it here by the time you
watch this video I will have been using
this phone for about half a week or so
so about four days so that's not quite
enough time for me to give my full
review of this phone but it is enough
time for me to get to know this phone a
lot better and I learned a bunch of new
things about it and a lot of these
things have to do with Android and the
software it's running so this is the
first phone running Android 7.1 out of
the box so not even 7.0 so usually a
point one update is a pretty sizable
update but a lot of these things you're
going to notice are still little tweak
updates from Android 7.0 even so
nevertheless these are five of my
favorite observations from a couple of
days so far using the pixel so number
one is the new navigation bar at the
bottom of the screen design is a little
bit different you can see the buttons
are filled in now and it's grown on me a
little bit the other thing is not all
phones have software buttons so that's
something you have to get used to I've
switched phones a lot between on screen
and off screen buttons so I came from
the 1 plus 3 so the big old [ __ ] on this
phone I found myself like tapping in
that empty space to go back or go
multitask that doesn't do anything
there's nothing down there it's just the
software buttons but yeah like I said
I've gotten used to the new look and I'm
actually using the assistant a bit more
than I use now on tap you can see
there's this little animation now for
pressing home and of course the long
press home will get you to the new
assistant so number 2 let's talk about
that
the assistant so on pixel phones it's
baked into the OS so like you saw a long
press of home will open it as far as I
know this is only on pixel phones so on
other Android phones you can get to the
assistant with the alo app or something
like that but the way works here is
pretty clean and familiar you have the
long press and it starts
listening and you can also say okay
Google from anywhere on any screen or
even when the phone is off to get it to
start listening to you and take a
command or question if there's stuff on
my screen I can hold home and then
actually swipe up to get potentially
useful information based on what it's
reading on my screen so that's still
useful from now on tap so number three
is the completely finished pixel
launcher so a bunch of you might have
been like me and we're using the apk of
the pixel launcher before on some other
phones but now this is the final version
and there's also actually still so many
things for those who weren't using it
number one thing you'll notice is the
circular icons yes there are circles
everywhere it's not entirely consistent
like you still have the alo icon is not
a circle for example the Dropbox icon is
not a circle but the one thing you can
say is that they're now all the same
size so you couldn't say that before but
that minor adjustment actually makes a
big difference to feeling clean and this
launcher you now swipe up to get into
your app drawer instead of pressing a
button actually have grown to really
like that so it gives you a way bigger
touch target to swipe up from instead of
having to hit a button in the middle of
the phone it's actually easier if your
reach and then you can just swipe
anywhere from the dock area so that
gives me an extra slot in my dock for
another favorite app also at the top of
the launcher is a clickable weather
forecast now it actually goes to your
weather and in the launcher settings you
actually also now have something called
app suggestions which I turned off but
it'll literally show you in your app
drawer an app that you don't have
installed just because it thinks you
might want to have it so I probably
would turn that off all right so number
four might look familiar to people who
have used a certain other smartphone
recently and that is the ability to long
press any icons on your homescreen
or in your app drawer to get functions
inside of your apps so the Twitter app
for example you could long press the
icon and it will give you a shortcut to
go right to your DMS or right to
composing a new tweet this reminds you
of 3d touch on the iPhone so while Apple
sort of developed this really
technically impressive proprietary
display technology for sensing pressure
Google just built it into a long press
so yeah a lot of Google first party apps
now have this functionality freshly
baked in because they were expecting it
but yeah more and more third-party apps
will soon start to have this as well so
I'm ready for that I'm assuming the
rollout will
a lot like the way it did with 3d touch
on iOS not sure how much I'll use it
because again I mean if you're an iPhone
user honestly how much do you use 3d
touch some more than others maybe you do
more than me but it's a cool feature I
just think it's cool that they figured
that out and they built it right into
the phone and then this number five last
but not least something pretty small
called gestures or moves so if you go to
the settings you'll see a section just
called moves and it's for some new
gestures three main new things one is
you can switch between the front and
back cameras and the camera app with a
double twist so it's kind of similar to
what you did in the Motorola camera app
back in the day to open the camera
number two is to double tap the power
button to open the camera this isn't new
we've seen this before and other nexuses
but again it allows you to not have a
camera shortcut on your phone you can
just double tap the power button and the
third and final thing is you can use the
finger probe reader on the back to swipe
up and down to pull down the
notification tray from anywhere and also
pull it back up so that's pretty cool I
turn that on I definitely do have some
accidental swipes when I'm just holding
the phone and handling the phone but for
the most part if I made an effort to
think about it it actually works as a
shortcut to just swipe down and check
the time and then swipe back up and if I
have a notification I'll see it pretty
quickly so there you have it it's a
bunch of small refinement type stuff on
Android 7.1 on this pixel phone
obviously the full review is coming soon
so what I want you to do is let me know
in the comments section right below that
like button what you want to see in the
full review obviously the camera that's
a major one that I want to test its so
far looking really promising and I have
good initial impressions but that's
something I want to test battery life I
have the excel again so far so good but
stuff like that let me know what you
guys want to know about this phone and
that will surely be tested for the full
review video either way that's been it
thank you for watching I'll talk to you
guys the next one peace
[Music]